después de varios días de duras críticas
e indignación por la escasez de las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 los
laboratorios de facer bayón tec y de
modernas aumentarán sus entregas a la
unión europea que hasta ahora ha
recibido 17 a 6 millones de dosis del
suero de la alianza farmacéutica y
854.000 del fármaco de moderna la
paralización de la producción de las
inyecciones genera un polémico retraso
en el calendario de la distribución de
las vacunas
estamos trabajando con empresas
farmacéuticas para garantizar que las
vacunas se entreguen a los europeos
vayan tec fighter entregará 75 millones
de dosis adicionales en el segundo
trimestre del año y hasta 600 millones
en total en 2021 los miembros
comunitarios están muy por detrás de
israel reino unido o eeuu en el
despliegue de vacunas con europa sumida
en una virulenta tercera ola de
coronavirus los países europeos están
lidiando con la demora de las entregas
de los fabricantes de inyecciones
occidentales algo inaceptable para
muchos líderes que han mostrado
preocupación sobre las negociaciones con
los laboratorios
y creo que los europeos también debemos
ser aún más eficientes en este asunto
sé que esa es también la voluntad de la
canciller merkel y de la presidenta
ursula von der leyen continuaremos a las
próximas semanas y meses acelerando las
cosas para ir más rápido en este tema de
cara a nuestras poblaciones pero también
para acompañar mejor a nuestros aliados
gestión venidos a compañeros y no de mí
hasta el momento la unión europea ha
autorizado tres vacunas modernas facer
vayan tec y astrazéneca pero tiene
contratos de adquisición con otras tres
farmacéuticas johnson and johnson your
back y sanofi todavía sin autorización
oficial y están negociando con los
laboratorios va al nevá y novavax lo que
elevará ocho el número de vacunas
disponibles para los países del bloque